labor is calling for an investigation
into whether the Home Secretary broke
the ministerial code by asking for
special treatment dealing with a
speeding offense let's speak to our
chief political correspondent John Craig
evening John so what's the allegation
here well what happened was that when
she was attorney general shortly before
she became Home Secretary last year she
was caught speeding and she was given
the option of the fine the points uh a
speed awareness course but she tried to
dodge all of those because what she
wanted to do was have a one-to-one
session on a speeding awareness course
rather than take part in a group because
she didn't want the publicity because
that would all be very public she didn't
want the points because of the fares
that her fears that that would mean
higher in car insurance premiums so she
asked her civil servants if they could
help her Dodge the fine by arranging
this private one-to-one driving
awareness course now the civil servants
said no they consulted the cabinet
office who backed their decision and now
there is an Almighty Rao with both labor
and the liberal Democrats saying there
needs to be an inquiry by Laurie Magnus
now he is the city Tycoon a city
establishment figure a grand grand D Who
was appointed by Rishi sunak last
December as his ethics advisor advising
on the ministerial code and labor and
the lib Dems are both saying that Sue
Ella bravaman as well as potentially
breaking that code is guilty of uh one
rule for her and another for everyone
else
um the shadow Home Secretary Yvette
Cooper who's leading the charge says
that these reports first appeared in the
that first appeared in the Sunday Times
were shocking and Yvette Cooper says the
prime minister's prime minister has
promised Integrity professionalism and
accountability yet it appears his home
secretaries blatantly flouting all three
we need an urgent investigation into
what has gone on here starting with
Laurie Magnus seeing how this is
potentially compatible with the
ministerial code worth pointing out that
two other home office ministers have
breached traffic rules uh Tom tugunart
was convicted of using his mobile phone
while driving and uh and Robert generic
was caught speeding on the M1 but this
is potentially serious because it does
look as though
Sue Ella bravaman did try and get
special treatment and the opposition
parties are crying foul and demanding an
investigation and of course she was had
to quit as homosexury briefly last year
here for another breach that was when
she leaked official material to Tori MP
Sir John Hayes so more questions for uh
the embattled uh suela bravaman tonight